well we've got this very very um
narrow path if you like careful balance
between on the one hand obviously
inflation is
well above target and you know our job
is to bring it back down to target and
achieve price to bring it back to where
it must be
on the other hand we've got a very big
predominantly external shock or series
of shocks
hitting the economy
hitting the real income of households
companies in this country and this is
kind of historic stuff really isn't it
it is
it is and we've also got a very tight
labor market in this country yeah i go
around the country a lot talk to
businesses
and they're talking you know their their
worry is how do i re how do i recruit
enough people for my business
so we're trying to balance this
we think most of the work to bring
inflation down will be done by
unfortunately the severity and scale of
this shock
to real incomes which i'm i mean i have
to you know i'm afraid to say it's got
worse in in the last three months since
we last produced a report because
obviously
of the impact of the terrible events uh
in ukraine
and do you i mean the scale of what's
facing households at the moment what's
what's your advice to to many people who
are just trying to make ends meet right
now
it is really difficult at the moment
is it going to get worse
well we do think that inflation is going
to
get uh hot somewhat higher as the year
goes by the reason i'm afraid that you
know we i'm afraid to have a reasonably
high probability of that happening is
the way in which the domestic energy
price setting mechanism operates we're
into the window now of
data that are collected to reset it in
the autumn
and prices were high even higher during
the early part of the window because i
think really during the initial period
of the
russian invasion it's come down a bit
since then but they're still higher
so unfortunately at the moment as things
stand and as you know we're forecasting
we have to look at higher energy prices
at the end of this year
now you ask
why are we raising interest rates today
and you know and we were very careful
it's a very very difficult balance we're
striking but there are risks
from the
tightness of the labor market
the encouraging signs of activity that
we saw earlier in the year i mean one of
the good pieces of news is that the
effect of omicron was a lot we didn't
think it was going to have a big effect
it had even less effect actually than we
thought it was
so we have to balance that because there
are risks to further a further increase
in inflation particularly coming from
just the sheer tightness of the labor
market yeah unemployment is at 3.8
percent now of course that's a very good
news story in many ways but of course it
does create a very tight labor market
and that's a risk to inflation so we're
trying to walk this very narrow path and
strike this balance but bluntly you are
making life tougher for families right
now aren't you well what would make it
even tougher for families as if
inflation kept on rising even more i
mean i have to be honest about that
that's a risk that is a risk and it
would be even if that would be even
tougher so we have to take that into
consideration and do and you know right
now you're already talking about
inflation getting up to over 10 the
highest level since the early 80s
as the governor you know it's your job
to try and keep it close to two percent
i mean how does that feel seeing it sky
high it's extremely uncomfortable i
don't want to make any bones about it
but the fact of the matter is this we
are being struck by
historically large shocks
i mean let's face it who you know who of
us thought there would be a war in
europe of the sort that we're seeing
it's terrible
do you think is there anyone you know a
lot of people are suffering economically
talking about economically a lot of
people are suffering right now is there
anyone who who is benefiting at the
moment
well i don't think
i don't think it's right to think about
benefits because of course inflation
hits everybody
what i worry about is there's a
distribution you know money distribution
and and what is i think important that
we bear in mind here is the particular
nature of the inflation we're having at
the moment because it's most
concentrated
in energy
food quite a bit of a number of food
related food goods
and
when you look at the consumption
patterns of people and you divide it up
into income groups
because energy and food
i mean the core for all of us i mean we
all have to you know consume them
you find that the lower income groups
relatively consume more of those things
because they relatively consume less of
the non-essentials
and the the thing that worries me and
concerns me is that of course therefore
relatively speaking it hits the least
well-off
those with least bargaining power in the
labor market the hardest so this could
be bad for inequality for the gaps
between halves and habits
is there anything the bank can do about
that well the best thing the bank can do
obviously is do everything we can which
we are doing is to get inflation back
down again
to take care of this issue
okay all right governor thank you very
much thank you so much